[Music]
this is a big issue with kids and
raising kids especially the kids you
have because i have kids of similar ages
is they all want the phones with the
apps and we don't let them have that
stuff but it's it's a problem like i
just don't let them have it yeah it's
easy you say no you can't have it
it's you know it's bad for you
but i want i don't care what you want
it's not that's not even
it doesn't need anything i love i don't
care what you want don't care what you
want
i'm not there to make them happy
really no mike that's great that's a
terrific philosophy it is
my role i'm not raising uh the children
i'm raising the grown-ups that they're
gonna be so i i have to raise them with
the tools to get through a terrible life
that's the way i look at it
i hope you tell them this just before
you turn out the light and shut the door
exactly your life will be horrible click
slam but no some parents really struggle
with like all the other kids have the
terrible things so my kid has to yeah
let's let you know let your kid go and
be a better example to the kids she
doesn't just because the other stupid
kids have phones
doesn't mean that okay well my kid has
to be stupid otherwise she'll feel weird
right
you know i i think these things are
toxic i don't think especially for kids
it's just this thing it's bad and they
don't look at people when they talk to
them and they don't build the empathy
you know kids are mean and it's because
they're trying it out
they they look at a kid and they go
you're fat and then they see the kid's
face scrunch up and they go oh that
doesn't feel good to make a person do
that but they but they got to start with
doing the mean thing but when they write
your fat then they just go
that was fun i liked them
so
that tasted good yeah exactly you need
the thing is i you need to build an
ability to just be yourself and not be
doing something that's what the phones
are taking away yes is the ability to
just sit there
like this that's being a person right
yes no one can they gotta
got to check
because
you know underneath everything in your
life there's that thing that empty
forever empty you know what i'm talking
about
that yes yes yes i yes
yes
that it's all for nothing and you're
alone you know it's down there
and sometimes when things clear away
you're not watching and you're in your
car
and you start going oh no here it comes
that i am alone like it starts to visit
on you you know just the sadness yes
life is tremendously sad just by you
know being in it and so you're driving
and then you go uh that's why we text
and drive i look around pretty much 100
of people driving or texting yes and
they're killing everybody's murdering
each other with their cars yes but
people are willing to risk taking a life
and ruining their own
because they don't want to be alone for
a second because it's so hard i was in
my car one time and a bruce springsteen
song comes on
and it made me really say it's like
jungle what the what's on the jungle
jungle land jungle this one where he
goes
and he sounds far away
and it's really far away sounding
can you do it with the reverb can you do
it
no they're not doing it they're not
trying to so
name it
like that yeah
except for it with spring seat if it was
you doing that i would have been like
what the hell is that in my radio
i did it just the same yeah
and i heard it and it gave me kind of
like a fall back to school depression
feeling made me really sad yeah and i go
okay i'm getting sad i gotta get the
phone and write hi to like 50 people
and then you know somebody cool writes
back and then somebody noticed cool
writes after and i'm like [ __ ] you i'm
not gonna somebody better
but uh
hey how come you didn't answer my text
speaking of which yeah well
yeah cause he wrote he wrote first
that's right
so
anyway i started to get that sad feeling
and i was reaching for the phone and i
said you know what don't
just be sad
just let the sad just stand in the way
of it and let it hit you like a truck
and i let it come and bruise
and i just started to feel oh my god and
i pulled over and i just cried like a
[ __ ] i cried
so much
and i and it was beautiful it was like
this beautiful just this sadness is
poetic you're lucky to live sad moments
and then i had happy feelings because
because when you let yourself feel sad
yes your body has like antibodies it has
happiness that comes rushing in rushing
in to meet the sadness so you're i was
grateful to feel sad
and then i met it with true
profound happiness it was such a trip
you know and the thing is because we
don't want that first bit of sad yeah we
push it away with like a little phone
third
for the food
and you get
you get a little kind of
you never feel completely sad or
completely happy you just feel kind of
satisfied with your product yes
and then you die
so
that's why i don't want to get a phone
for my kids